stop the stigma everyone deserves
authentic welcome and a place to belong
there's nothing completely wrong with
you we're calling it as you've heard
stop the stigma it's a conversation
about mental health we want to make this
a conversation an ongoing conversation
if you will to take away the shame and
the blame and that's something
emmy-winning broadcast journalists and
we're proud to say our colleague Jane
Pauley is very passionate about after
more than 30 years reporting the news
Polly put a very public face on bipolar
disorder she revealed that she had taken
a break from the spotlight and spent
three weeks in a psychiatric clinic
after being diagnosed back in 2001 and
now here's the big picture an estimated
seven million Americans live with
bipolar disorder it's an illness that
can cause dramatic mood swings from
depressive lows to manic highs and Jane
is now an advocate for mental health as
well as the host of our beloved CBS
Sunday Morning Anita thank you for being
mm when you were diagnosed and I should
point out that the majority of people
who experience mental illness
experienced it and are diagnosed before
the age of 24 in your case you were 53
kids married successful career very busy
career what was it like to get the
diagnosis well when I was 49 I was not
bipolar when I was 50 I was I was
switched a flipped these are medical
terms of art I treated for hives
medication that wouldn't have been given
to someone at least without protection
and careful observation if a doctor had
reason to think that there was family
history or prior history with a mood
disorder I didn't have that you had no
family history no no no
that I know of yeah yeah but it it
unmasked what doctors then described as
a genetic vulnerability yeah to a mood
disorder and by that time I was in
pretty deep trouble it's pretty
interesting that the in terms of
experiencing stigma one of the direct
ways that you did is your own doctor who
suggested maybe you don't want to tell
the public about this whole thing and
even gave you a little cover story I
want to tell talk about stigma a little
bit later when you tell me I can but the
only time in my life and it's been we're
closing in on 20 years that I
experienced stigma was that day day one
when I recognized that my doctor was
giving me a cover story to tell my
employers that I was being treated for a
thyroid disorder which was true but I
knew it was more than the whole truth
yeah and I poor guy I said you know I'm
already writing a book and the working
title is sky riding a life out of the
blue this will fit right in
he went pale but I knew then that with
my reputation on television I Western
this happened to you yes because I know
my family had checked other boxes but
not that one itself you wrote that the
only way to redeem this horrible
situation was to talk about that's the
way I think and and when I told this my
doctor he kind of turned pale and I
didn't put out a press release I
everybody deserves an opportunity to
recover from whatever in private yes
understand how it manifests itself for
you we keep hearing you were diagnosed
so how did it change for you what was a
difference is I changed I it didn't
change for me it actually got better I
the side effect of the steroids for
hives was anted anti what was depression
treated with antidepressant were you
said we're angry what was depression is
depression and then over time it worked
and I got better and felt much better
and then felt really great and then
started having plans and other behaviors
that my husband didn't know who I was so
that when I finally you know when the
doctor finally recognized oh I know
what's going on here mm-hmm
this is bad yeah he called my husband
and he said your wife is very sick and
Gary was almost relieved well maybe
someone can help get my wife back you
don't like the word stigma we're calling
this program yes it is my personal
advocacy and I'm not an expert I'm
someone with bipolar don't take medical
advice from me but as a communicator I
know something words have power yes and
the word stigma is its own stress its
own stigma when you you know cancer used
to have a stigma and then Betty Ford and
then now we wear pink ribbons and run
for the Cure the the yellow bracelets
Michael J Fox fights Parkinson's with
hope with a positive message so every
time you say stigma it is a reminder of
people for people like me that I'm
fighting two wars yeah it's not enough
that I have a disorder that's pretty
serious
but I've also fighting this front so my
goal is that we fight stigma which is
real mm-hmm but we fight it with
sophistication and we normalized this
company
yes it's a medical disorder and there is
good news we're now wearing ribbons and
if there's a 5k I'm sure everyone in
this room would run in it yeah Jane
Pauley thank you very much for being
here we have a list of mental health
resources and guides available on our
website CBS this morning dot-com slash
mental health and remember if you or
someone you know is ever experiencing a
crisis you can call 911